welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka butt man and
it's been a big week for Batman with
tons of rebels dropping for the film
every week same bat-time same
bat-channel we break down all of the
biggest updates in the movie and this
week there's a hell of a lot to unpack
after giving our reaction to the new
Batmobile on Wednesday I thought I'd
take a closer look at the car to see
what exactly has gone into it we also
have some casting news that has been a
lot of speculation over as well as a
potential location for the Batcave there
may be some spoilers here so if you want
to go into the film as blind as possible
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now make sure you subscribe to the
channel to never miss a video
and without the way shout outs Alex
reader and all of the people who helped
me to get to 200,000 subscribers it
means a lot a massively appreciated you
guys are the best
now let's get into the video thank you
okay so Matt Reeves released three
images of the Batmobile earlier in the
week that had Robert Pattinson or at
least someone wearing the Batsuit sister
beside it this has often been a
tradition when Batman movies drop a
first look and after getting email
Affleck for Batman V Superman we have
the mad mechanic feel for this film the
Batmobile has a very handmade feel to it
and it definitely looks like someone has
taken an existing vehicle and
transformed it into the Caped Crusader's
car because of this there's a lot of
speculation a Bruce mayor put together
or himself or that Al Kooper did in case
you don't know L Cooper was a character
in the animated series that was the top
flight engineer for global motors he
became a whistleblower that exposed the
company for their safety defects and the
corporation sent thugs after him in
order to silence the character Batman
bust them up and saved his life and
after he was blacklisted the Dark Knight
went to him with a job to build the
Batmobile in the show he maintained it
and I do think that Batman will need
someone by his side to help with the
upkeep of the ride whether this role is
just mushed into Alfred we will see but
it's a nice theory that I've seen
discussed online as for the car itself
it looks very in line with the 1970s
Dodge Challenger the car was a very
famous model during the 70s and it's
notorious for its loud engine and power
the muscle car that we see in the images
has been built upon in several ways most
notably its engine which has been moved
to the back of the ride though we don't
know what this is for exactly it is
possible that the front has been
repurposed for something else we do know
from Ash Dobbs comments in the film that
this will be a very DIY Batman and this
has been showcased in a suit bat bike
and now the car I would hazard a guess
that the front has been fitted out to
store in a modder of weapons and gadgets
that Wayne has made himself and these
have been moved up top so that the car
has a lot of power at the back the
vehicle has two enormous exhausts that
travel vertically at the side of the car
and the engine itself is a v10 ten
cylinder piston this gets the name of
b10 because well there are ten cylinders
that are all arranged in the B shape
around the crankshaft basically yeah I
don't know that much about cars but
apparently it means it will be fast very
very fast
v10 engines were first produced in 1965
and they were later made for road cars
in 1994 currently we don't know
specifically when the new Batman film is
set and has been speculated as being set
in the 90s all the way up to modern day
this application does let us know that
the earliest the film can be set is 1994
so at least at least that narrows it
down a bit to the last 25 years
coupled with the engines as an
afterburner and it's clear that the main
cars purpose is speed to me it feels
very much like the first iteration of
the Batmobile and I can see this getting
upgraded throughout the franchise I've
seen comparisons to John Wick's muscle
car death race and a lot of others and I
definitely feel like it fits the world
that they're going for you can tell that
the design team has just sat down and
thought right this is the Batman that we
want to make what would a Batman like
that look like and what would they write
this is the most down-to-earth depiction
of ever seen even probably more grounded
than Nolan's version and I think the
influences from Batman are well are very
clear here everything feels tangible and
similar to the art by Lieber Meho it's
all very consistent and real feeling I
love when designers do this as you can
clearly see what vision you are getting
often in films if they drop something in
without thinking about how it mirrors
the world it stands out like a sore
thumb
Ghostbusters reboot I think we will
eventually get something similar to the
car from the well and I was actually
quite surprised to see some people on
the internet disappointed that it was
just a car
I think the bat tank from the nola
movies and Arkham Knight has reinforced
the idea that Batman tends to have
something more than a car but often in
the comics he just tends to have one
with a couple of pins strapped on it
judging by the tone of the film this is
a Batman that is going to be fighting
robbers and low-level criminals and not
doomsday or Superman personally I think
it would be overkill to overdo it and
I'm glad that it's toned back as it lets
us know that this is a realistic version
of the character in addition to this we
also got to casting adverts from
Universal extras who are filming outdoor
shots in the middle of March they
require male and female extras to take
part in scenes shooting over the 16th
17th 18th 19th and 22nd of March so it's
probably gonna be a very busy week here
at the channel this is to fill the
streets of a busy city and on top of it
the company has called for people at dry
black town cause people in the UK drive
on the opposite side to Americans but as
the movie is set in America they require
these types of vehicles so keep an eye
out that week and if you live in
Liverpool I'd definitely recommend that
you head out this could potentially be
more bad bike scenes but the fact that
they have released an image of the
Batmobile similar to how they released
the super for the outdoor filming on the
bike tells me that it will most likely
be the car that is getting shot during
this so they're going for a realistic
gritty and grounded feel with not only
the car but also the surroundings
earlier this week we had a post on
subreddit DCE leaks which I got banned
from for posting Batman leaks go figure
and it said the following liverpool
native here they're currently setting up
for filming around st. George's Hall in
the city centre specifically they seem
to be planning to film on the passageway
that leads from William Brown Street
down into the cells underneath the hall
they've got a green screen at the end of
the street so it's definitely going on
inside I've got no idea of they're doing
interior filming but they're definitely
using that long passageway it goes right
through the building and out the other
side the police used to use it to drop
off and pick up creme
from the cell good chance they're using
the interiors to they then linked the
following picture that you can see in
the screenshot and also an additional
one of the halls underneath they still
look a lot like cells and if you remove
the images that are on the wall I could
definitely see this being a prison and
there have been a number of suggestions
thrown up from Arkham Asylum to kill a
Crocs lair and a lot more personally I
believe that it may either be the
Riddler's hideout
who needs to have access to a lot of
things in Gotham at once or Batman for
the same reason the cabin does
aesthetically fit in with the look of
the Batmobile so if I had to guess
anything I would say that it may be the
Batcave Batman does need a lair and the
way that the infrastructure of this
location has been built into the
surrounding areas
makes me think that it could be
connected to Wayne Tower Wayne Manor and
a lot more of the key locations in
Gotham
this would allow Batman to seemingly
appear and disappear around the city and
it would add a lot of weight to its
legend the green screen could be used to
potentially show a background image like
a waterfall which are known to be seen
in the Batcave and there's a lot of
potential here for locales now before we
get into the rest of the video I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the Infinity Saga box set
to one random subscriber all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning
it's like the video subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts and the
updates in the comment section below but
when it's gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of March in this that'll be
shipped out from the enter gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part and finally the last
story that I think is worth covering is
the casting of Max and Charlie Carver
this is a distinctive thing to know
because the two twins really could fit a
variety of roles in Gotham the story was
broken by AV Club and the internet
immediately jumped to the assumption
that they would be playing tweedledee
and tweedledum personally the two
lumbering Giants don't really fit the
look of the actors and many people
agreed with this and a theory that they
were the Abramovic twins started rising
these two conjoined circus folk were big
parts of the Arkham franchise and as we
know the film is casting circus
performers so it is indeed possible that
the pair could be fitting those roles
however I have a completely different
theory that ties in with one of our
earlier videos if you've been keeping up
to date with the channel
then you know that an insider contacted
me and let me know that the majority of
the film was pulling from Batman earth 1
I'll leave that video linked at the end
as we provide evidence to how we can
tell the person those the details on the
film it's definitely worth checking out
so yeah give it a watch after this
anyway earth 1 is interesting because in
volume 2 of that book we are actually
introduced to the dent twins that play
the parts of Gotham's DA and Gotham's
mayor we already know that the death of
the mayor is going to be a big part in
the work and this election could link in
with that by the end of the work one of
them is dead and the other is badly
injured and the survivor takes on the
personality of the one who was a very
angry and brutal man with us already
having a Harvey Dent origin story so
recently in The Dark Knight
I can definitely see this potentially
being Harvey Dent either as a twin or
with the other playing the most
distinctive part of his personality it
could have him playing off against
himself in a mirror
similar to Norman Osborn or they could
be two separate characters to me they
look like what I'd imagined Harvey Dent
- and as we know the storyline is
pulling from the long Halloween which is
a two-face origin story there's a lot of
food for thought but hopefully you've
enjoyed the theories and this is giving
you something to think about as
mentioned earlier we do breakdowns in a
Batman every week same bat-time same
bat-channel
- make sure you stay locked - never miss
any of the information if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the exclusive leak which is
gonna be linked at the end if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below you get access to
content early and can suggest video
topics and breakdowns we massively
appreciate it and it goes a long way to
helping videos like this get made you
wanna come check us out to the show
either follow us at definition whitey or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]